aujourd'hui je vais vous raconter une
histoire c'est l'histoire de squeeze en
2013 qui tomba sur un commentaire sur
l'une de ces vidéos
ce commentaire a été postée par
quelqu'un qui m'informait qu'il pensait
sincèrement que j'avais un trouble du
déficit de l'attention avec ou sans
hyperactivité et chose qui m'a
traumatisé à l'époque c'est que le mec
avait il fait une liste de tout ce qui
lui faisait penser que j'étais atteint
de ce truc là et vu que dès que j'ai un
peu mal quelque part j'ai l'impression
que c'est tout de suite un cancer eh ben
c'est commentaire m'a beaucoup affecté
j'avais fait mes petites recherches et
au final je ne pense pas être attendu
tout mais je n'ai jamais eu la certitude
puisque il faut voir un [ __ ] de
psychologues pour le savoir généralement
ces diagnostics et quand tu es en forme
et ça peut être diagnostiqué bien plus
tard pourquoi parce que les symptômes de
cette maladie et ben tout le monde les a
mais en beaucoup moins fort je
m'explique ta jeu j'avais préparé ce
courage-là prépa j'aime aussi beaucoup
arrosé les malades sont atteints de
trois gros symptômes l'inattention
l'hyperactivité et l'impulsivité
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'on a tous
du mal à se concentrer sur certains
trucs on est tous parfois hyper active
on est tous plus ou moins impulsif donc
quelqu'un qui atteint de cette maladie
des fois il ne le sait pas pendant très
très très longtemps
tout ça pour dire qu'aujourd'hui on va
faire un quizz pour savoir si on est
atteint ou pas d'un trouble du déficit
de l'attention avec ou sans
hyperactivité donc sur vous il a été
fait par des spécialistes du tdah ceva
n'est ce pas des conneries pour une fois
c'est pas revu son savoir si tu es
plutôt ses reportages ou des fonds d'or
mais attention qu elle prenne du recul
ça vous dit que vous êtes atteints du
tdah eux se trouve être par acer est un
quiz sur internet fera des conneries
c'est parti je fais toujours des petites
erreurs on travaille julie vite j'ai
tendance à précipiter les choses petites
erreurs oui je lis pas du tout et j'ai
tendance à précipiter les choses ça
c'est vrai moi dans ma vie je suis hyper
speed tout doit aller vite même les
mêmes un truc qui me saoule dans les
jeux par exemple dangbo sais que je peux
aller vite tout le temps tout faire vite
et du coup je pourrais même plus de
plaisir à faire ce que j'ai à faire dans
le jeu voilà j'ai mon avis je fais faut
arrimer rendez-vous j'obtiens des
chiffres erronés et je fais pas
attention aux fautes d'orthographe
ah non c'est tout moi j'ai souvent
négligé des détails de leur opus hd
formulaire oublier d'ajouter une pièce
jointe avait email globalement pour ma
part c'est non je suis un orthographe
nazis mais cette fois je fais des fautes
d'orthographe
globalement c'est non ça me rassure je
suis facilement distraits ça dans mon
cas c'est très très grave et c'est
d'ailleurs ce symptôme là qu'il m'a fait
penser à l'époque que jamais ce truc je
trouve qu'il est difficile de faire des
tâches longue voire même des activités
longue des loisirs quoi oui c'est vrai
sauf au vin rouge à ça le tdah il est
plat et plus rien une mauvaise écoute au
[ __ ] ça mais que c'est chaud je trouve
que je suis facilement distrait pendant
les conversations plus longue
j'ai tendance à m'éteindre c'est
horrible mais c'est vrai sauf quand je
suis avec un groupe de personnes ou
l'ass avoir fait ça ça c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que j'ai du mal à garder le
rythme en fait quand il ya une grosse
discussion tu peux regarder quelqu'un de
légers mais je suis perdu dans mes
pensées mon esprit vagabonde souvent ça
c'est vraiment mais mes gros avec le
tout cas c'est mon gros problème je
n'arrive pas à rester concentrer sur
quelque chose très longtemps mais
j'arrive pas mais par contre quand je
concentre sur un truc c'est vraiment à
fond je leur ai offert le tav le tas
bloc mais ça peut pas durer longtemps
mais là l'école quand je faisais mes
devoirs je me souviens je possède trente
minutes pas plus j'y arrivais pas par
contre pour les 30 minutes j'étais aux
chaînes dont je t'ai jamais un toc
attention dossier j'ouvrais mon livre
comme ça voilà c'est les post it c'est
un peu de la merde et je lisais avoir
recours et j'étais obligé de tourner en
rond comme ça je faisais des 8
je faisais des serpentins et quand je
récitais le cours à l'inversé la même
chose et sastre et si elle disait
arrêtera si toi et si je vais essayer
que j'arrêtais de marché j'arrive plus à
me souvenir des trucs voilà c'est
vraiment passionnant ce qui se passe
bref continent je passe souvent à côté
de ce qu'on me dit je dois donc demandé
aux gens de se répéter à azé l'histoire
de ma vie mon bien avec tous les jours
enfin opus était vendeur vin ngo gates a
demandé de faire quelque chose tu sais
que la personne a bien insisté mais tu
te souviens plus
je suis là plus pour tenter à écouter et
là tu dois lui demander de répéter tu
sais que cette personne n'a pensé
beaucoup de mal de toi
elle va penser que tu en a rien à [ __ ]
d'elle que tu la déteste que toute
manière tu l'écoutés jamais est
intéresse pas alors c'est faux et ce qui
est étrange c'est que mon frère il a
exactement le même problème
et du coup comment pas un peu vite mais
dubaï a plein de trucs qui sont
similaires parce qu'on a les mêmes
problèmes en fait des comportements
selon cette loi parce que des fois je le
raconte une anecdote sur un truc est en
fait cette anecdote c'est lui qui me l'a
raconté deux jours avant mais j'ai
oublié et lui fait là le mec moi
du coup ces arbres les conversations et
de demeurer profond alors qu'on est
jeunes coincés mais pourtant on s'écoute
chez page c'est pour ça que j'ai
vraiment pensé que j'avais ça il ya des
années parce que au final je finissais
presque par en souffrir en échec les
gens qui ont un tdah là les symptômes de
fonds par les bla bla bla mais c'est
vraiment pas marrant c'est des gens qui
en souffrent énormément au quotidien et
en plus ils sont pas vraiment pris au
sérieux par leur entourage parce qu'ils
disent mais c'est bon ou tout mauvais
comme ça est en fait des caisses alors
que non c'est une maladie non c'est
vraiment poussé à l'extrême
bref je préfère les mettre immédiatement
plutôt que de lire les instructions les
guides ou les recettes
oui
bof pas excessif c'est je pense que sur
ça je suis dans la normalité quoi je
n'ai pas de routine régulière au travail
ou à la maison
je lutte avec les horaires ou les plans
aux soucis moi j'ai une bonne routine de
bâtard voilà c'est pas moi je ne suis
pas obstiné
je sais quoi faire je n'arrive juste pas
à le faire ouais ça ouais ça va j'ai du
mal à m'organiser [ __ ] j'ai du mal à
organiser mon horaire de travail ma vie
sociale et mes obligations familiales
hanoi youtube pour le coup je suis
vraiment je sais bien le seul truc que
j'avais organisé dans ma vie c'est ça le
jour tel jour telle jour je tourne
quelques jours je prends un bain dans
l'argent désabonner tel jour ça ça va
j'arrive à organiser j'ai du mal à me
mettre des fois mais une fois que je
mets mais je kiffe comme peau de chagrin
vers toi tu es petit tu cries chian n'a
pas envie d'y aller
l x qui est [ __ ] t'es tellement bien
la planification d'un grand projet
m'intimide pas énormément mais ça c'est
ça c'est tout le monde pour le coup tout
le monde quand tu es un gros projet bat
et intimident été ôtés était normal
d'ailleurs j'ai en plein dans la khl au
stream dont comment je fais cette vidéo
c'est pas encore l'enseigné ailleurs
j'ai même pas fait la vidéo d' avance
mais je suis comme ça quoi je
procrastine dont je remets au lendemain
tout le temps parce que je ne peux pas
voir par où commencer ou comprendre ce
dont j'ai besoin
non c'est juste que j'ai la flemme 100%
des humains c'est comme ça on a la
flemme on au lendemain mais non c'est
toi parce que je ne vois pas par où
commencer non j'ai du mal à terminer des
choses qui demande beaucoup de
concentration pendant une longue période
de temps d'autrefois j'arrive à mettre
complètement dedans et je suis hyper
concentré ouais bah c'est examen ça
c'est exactement ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est totalement ce que je fais
souvent je faire des choses comme mon
téléphone mais clé où ma télécommande
entre guillemets mais je le vis d'une
minute non je suis un nazi moga sur ça
la télécommande j'avais toujours un
endroit avec les pareil
et quand je perds l'un des deux j'ai
envie de tout péter mais c'est très rare
donc ça va du coup je casse pas tout
tout le temps ma maison est où mon
espace de travail est encombré il ya des
trucs partout les choses doivent être là
où je peux les voir sinon je crains de
les oublier
c'est totalement vrai mec c'est tout
c'est tout le bordel parce que j'avoue
j'adore voir les choses et quand je les
mets dans un tiroir mais tu peux être
sûr que j'y touche pas pendant une année
mais vraiment est vrai que c'est le
bordel là autour de moi et tu facilement
distraits par des conversations des
bruits ou des activités qui ont lieu
autour de toi ah ouais
ouais ça aussi c'est un truc plus donc
j'ai beaucoup souffert quant au
restaurant avec des gens j'arrive mieux
à comprendre et à écouter les
conversations qu'il ya autour
quel savoir ce qui se passe là où je
suis avec la personne j'ai oublié de
faire quelque chose donc je dois
retourner le faire et j'ai du mal à
retenir les prénoms à oued 2 ouvre mon
gars c'est catastrophe
en plus moi j'ai des toques de bâtard
genre c'est le toque du est-ce que j'ai
fermé le robinet en partant de la salle
de bain ce matin et est obligé de
remonter tout objet de vente et a permis
de rentrer sur avec salle de bain soit
inondé dont tu remontes j'oublie les
rendez-vous les promesses le nom deux
fois où cyprien m'a engueulé ou et m'a
dit [ __ ] mais l'udc alain taton
téléphone de connards de riches pourquoi
de demain tu ne peux pas les rendez-vous
que tu as ce à quoi je lui réponds oui
pardon m romain je vais le faire et
j'oublie et quand je promets un truc
pareil j'ai je fais l'effort temps j'ai
vraiment du mal à mon souvenir quoi
alors je travaille sur moi pour mon
souvenir quand je suis seul jeu par la
botte à moi même pour rester sur la
bonne voie alors ouais alors que seuls
ouais je parle un peu à moi même mais ça
c'est peut-être juste à schizophrénie
non mais ça non mais je pense que tu
montes de temps en temps par l'autre
voie alors je mette ça voilà je suis le
seul et là j'ai perdu 10 milliards
d'abonnés alors alors dit moi j'essaie
sur neuf un score de 5 ou plus suggère
un problème d'inattention alors que la
plupart des gens luttent avec certains
de ses symptômes cela ne signifie pas
qu'ils ont un trouble du déficit de
l'attention avec ou sans hyperactivité
il pourrait être stressé par des
événements majeurs de la vie ou tout
autre problème médical d'accord donc
ouais moi savez je suis hyper impulsif
bon je serai jamais un truc et huila
parce que d'un coup je m'enflamme mais
des fois ouais je m'enflamme un peu mais
à l'oral quoi dans ce que je dis
d'accord problème c'est juste que je
suis hyper actif et baroque écoute enfin
devrais je fasse ce quiz où je vois un
psychologue car si sur un vrai hyper
actif ou pas mais [ __ ] c'est ouf comme
même en faisant le quiz on se rend
compte qu'il ya vraiment plein de
symptômes que plein de gens ont tu as et
ils en font des caisses alors que des
fois ils n'ont pas beaucoup à la verse
des fois ils l'ont vraiment faire le
symptôme mais pense qu'ils n'ont pas
plus que les autres qu'ils en parlent
pas forcément c'est très très dur en
tout cas si certains d'entre vous ont
été diagnostiqués ayant un trouble du
déficit de l'attention avec ou sans
hyperactivité pas par exemple les
commentaires sur intéresse vraiment et
franches pour le maccabi ce commentaire
il ya quatre ans tu m'as et ont attisé
j'aimerais ont fait des recherches des
trous dans le ballon guerre et en plus
avec mon frère on n'arrête pas d'en
parler du fait que vous non plus tout en
tous répètent sans cesse les mêmes
choses des fois on croit à prendre un
ticket quelqu'un alors c'est cette
personne elle même qui nous l'a apprise
deux jours plus tôt je pense pas que tu
attendes ça mais moi je mets petits
problèmes de
tête en l'air de hyperactif apparemment
et n'hésitez pas à aller mais la vidéo
ça vous a plu bon diagnostic on a fait
n'hésitez pas à faire le quiz et
répondait vraiment sincèrement oui ou
non vous forcez pas à mes tweets comme
vous forcez pas maintenant si vous
voulez faire toute manière si vous avez
des doutes et que vous souffrez de quoi
que ce soit et bah allez voir un médecin
un psychologue ça vous aidera bien plus
qu'un quiz sur internet et je compte sur
vous pour envoyer de l'amour aux gens
qui sont malades qui ont été d ajouter
on voit que ce soit d'autre un problème
psychologique physique n'importe quoi
pour à j'avoue je suis sûr vous en
sortez comme des oufs
vous êtes des chefs et puis si certains
veulent parler leurs primes dans les
commentaires du coût de cette vidéo pas
pourquoi pas
voilà une sorte de forum bac général ce
ne sera pas trop fait chier je vous dis
un titre dans une prochaine vidéo moi je
vais prendre cette balle ont opposé des
fruits les cuisiner un petit peu à voile
attend encore quatre secondes c'est bon
placement produit est fait c'est par
delà son produit [ __ ] aller 21 ans
gratuit à tout le monde
amour
[Musique]
ça